non saprei spiegare che questa cosa
potrebbe insomma del carico si fanno
così come sempre guardato
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video su questo nuovo sul mio
canile
certo ho fatto questa battuta una volta
sola 234 punti non fa mai ridere
comunque perché non fare come quelli che
scrivono o dieci anni fa ridere non sono
qua con eugenio si chiama eugenio che un
cane bellissimo bellissimo con un nome
discutibilissimo però il cane bello
siamo qua perché oggi facciamo vito con
gli apo dove proveremo a capire se lui
dice la verità o meno perché oggi
abbiamo la macchina delle bugie
abbiamo portato a quando come la
facciamo vedere adesso non gli possono
muovere per ovvi motivi
[Musica]
le scarpe
ascoltami fatto sempre che sono qua oggi
ciò un gioco e scopro se tu dici la
verità 1 c'è una roba che esiste
incredibile dove se tu me la macchina si
ma schiava la macchina delle bugie
signoria capo qua dice un sacco di bugie
oggi c'è anche tua mamma poi che vorrei
farti un paio di domande le dice a me
che tanto non compare
e io te le faccio ma ragazzi anche oggi
ad un attacco brutale noi e mi dico
quasi mai fragile quasi ma ecco quel
quasi verrà completamente tolto con la
macchina delle bugie pesca togliamo
[Musica]
stiamo iniziando il gioco della macchina
delle bugie clamori together stavo a
casa
io non faccio niente lo farà domanda
allora a tante domande viene farò un
paio io un paio le prendono gioco questo
gioco anche delle vite quindi potrei di
seguire delle vite a lui e tenere io
però non ne utilizziamo solo le domande
del gioco ma possiamo anche inventarci
re come funziona questo gioco
incredibile questa qua e la spia della
metà bene questa la spia del nervosismo
questa è la spia di viene bugia ecco
facciamo noi ragione 3io di vita tu mi
devi fare la domanda e schiacciare il
pulsante rosso quando mai stato su
questa lampadina no quindi sei giusto si
dovrebbe illuminare di rosso si devono
togliere le bisogna togliere allora
prima domanda che ti faccio ti
piacerebbe avere venti o più anni
sì perché ho la patente è sbagliato non
ti piace e non ti diretti a gennaio ma
vogliamo avere la patente non ha
differenziato ma mi spiace è proprio per
questo motivo che non puoi avere più di
vent'anni perché anche se più di
vent'anni hanno 24 ma niente non ce l'ho
quindi sbagliato è giusto così questo
volevo dirti poi com'è che tutti sanno
che io non ho la patente smettila c'era
una figura di cine video prossima
domanda poi io so che hai fatto mille
prove per averla fatta in pieno ciò che
è uscito prossima domanda credi o non è
l'esistenza degli alieni
credi che esistano pazienti
non è vero non esistono ma perché
stamattina è che tu non sei le risposte
di lotta tu mi hai scritto veramente
crisi noi e linea non è che dice no se
noi non ci sarebbero gli altri piede di
sanremo le richieste di utilizzo la
stessa logica per dire ci sono tante
persone sulla terra perché sono single
ma che ne so che andiamo avanti a metter
eviteremo secondo me ti fai che secondo
me ti fa milano per caso ti finirà ma è
una degli analisti che gli ometti no non
voglio dire un po il killer godibile ma
chi è fortissimo pochissimo così questa
è buona ragazzi suoi veri figli si cela
supera già la dis qualcuno è possibile
non è vero non vedere non puoi pagare 6
marino 6 un bambino non può fai la cacca
più volte al giorno
mio papà si di centrato la domanda fase
di marte non è vero che la tua la
domanda ma edizione la tua vita che
faccio la doccia
ero che sei lì seduto sul lato e con i
cablè voi sapete che luigi fa la cacca
più volte al giorno
bene ti piacciono le persone con i
tatuaggi
sì perché nuova faccia
vabbè tuchel e iphone mio padre a
gianluca né una cosa posso farci mi
piace non me ne faccio anch'io
aspetta un attimo però quando tiscali ti
mangi le caccole ogni tanto vecchie
volta ma che il fisico
questa mattina da casa i miei sarà
pesanti cosa vuol dire solo per le reti
wi fi una volta fatto mistero ma dietro
la casa che scrive e poi sono frizzanti
ritrovati in di iscrizione si trovano in
giappone
cioè le tue calcoli e trovate in
descrizione merchandising delle grazie
[Applauso]
allora siccome le domande del gioco sono
tante programma anche a farne un po noi
ce lo inventiamo le stili a un 4 sempre
possiamo è sono tante una penna grazie è
negato un niente
un'altra prima grazie no abbiamo solo
questa usiamo iniziato a scrivere e poi
scrivo io davo aveva io le sto
appuntando male cioè non capisce niente
di quello che ho scritto
va bene allora la guarda no ma non puoi
capire quello per chi mai scoraggiato
mentre guarda visto in the things sì un
sacco di volte
sì è vero ma lo faccio spesso anche
adesso ma non se ne sta accorgendo
venire avete scuole per evitare
assolutamente sì
mamma ti ha mai baciato in bocca grazie
a dio
no no no questa volta ma per farlo
perché le marche si tiene tanto schifo
ragazze non è vero sei mai stato
bocciato
sì sette volte nello stesso esame perché
facevo una patente
non vedo l'ora che la faccia tu vai a
letto che metto cametti questo tocca me
s'è innamorato di una ragazzina no a
essere piccoli e sentire il mondo gente
dell'amore ma non puoi la mia macchina
le bugie questo è adesso domani vado in
classe tu e lo dico prima che tutti
iniziativa lezione che ti piace una
bambina metti lì dove vai e amati ma non
c'è solo che questo è difficile
prego vi ricordo che si è innamorato di
una ragazzina quindi potrei scegliere
ormai si è impossibile da mettere mi
vuoi bene davvero
ahi ahi ahi
io credevo nella nostra amicizia questa
è l'ultima amico mio amico solo da parte
mia da parte di un amico invece sempre
invece sei infatti questo è molto
cattiva
va bene dimmi tutto allora queste
macchinette rocca secondo te no forse un
possibile infatti ne approfitto per dire
che c'è scritto quarda nota per gli
adulti quindi eugenio il prodotto è un
giocattolo vabbè la modalità di gioco è
basata su un algoritmo che la macchina
non è in grado di rilevare alcuna verità
con precisione è certezza assoluta
quindi potresti volermi bene ma errata
non ne sono sicuro sono comunque un
altro bellissimo io me ne vado solo
triste calaio no no ma felici a buy
ma l'ultima questa è l'ultima amiche
fumarie dopo vuoi giocare con me che tu
mario prego non solo verdi non fare
verde non fare legge non farebbero fare
gioco
maledetto a me le ha fatte a quella che
mi hai fatto prima io ti ho risposto
secondo termale sperimentare le dita
mi vuoi bene rozzi
bravo hai fregato il gioco va bene però
mi è piaciuta bravo complimenti questa è
piaciuta questa e tattica anche nelle
verifiche vuoi fare così più o meno
adesso che la verità è vera non tarocca
possiamo concludere il medio ciao ciao
ragazzi a presto
[Musica]